donc pour commencer je me présente je
m'appelle mail d'alpha rg 22 ans donc je
viens d'annecy comme vous l'avez compris
je suis étudiante comme vous j'imagine
sauf que c'est un stade ce pas trop les
mêmes matières et ça fait neuf ans que
je pratique le parapente et en
compétition aussi et voilà je voulais
vous partager mon expérience de la
pression parce qu'en fait il faut savoir
qu'à la base je suis une jeune fille
quand même très timide et très sujettes
au stress comme maintenant d'ailleurs et
à côté de ça ben ouais voilà cette année
je suis devenue championne du monde et
donc ça m'a amené à me porter des
questions des questions sur les extrêmes
justement de la pression parce que je me
suis rendu compte que voilà sous la
pression il ya des sportifs qui arrivent
à produire leur meilleur performance
comme ami et je sais pas si vous
connaissez du ski où vous prenez le
chêne bolt et à côté de compliqué ici et
à côté de ça pas moi j'ai un ami en
passant sans permis il est tombé dans
les pommes
une fois deuxième permis à vomi un
l'enfer donc voilà la pression c'est
quand même ultra vaste et on a tous un
rapport à la pression qui est vraiment
différent j'aimerais j'aimerais mettre
les choses au point avec vous parce
qu'il est vrai qu'il ya pas très
longtemps j'ai dit un ami je venais
faire cette conférence le et que le
sujet était sous pression et tout de
suite son réflexe a été de prendre part
à les jouer de me dire ballom au petit
muet ont des sous pression et du coup je
me suis dit bon mais qu'est ce qu'on
pense de la pression de nos jours et
qu'est ce que moi je pense de la
pression déjà pour essayer de comprendre
et je me suis dit c'est vrai que j'ai
toujours vu ça comme quelque chose de
deux mâles en fait comme quand on te
comme quelque chose qu'il faut pas avoir
et il sous pression c'est tout juste
quelque chose dans ce sens soumis à la
pression elle est plus grande que nous
et donc à partir de là je me suis dit
pourquoi pas se mettre à la même hauteur
qu'elle pourquoi pas
déjà partir d'égal à égal pour essayer
déjà travaillé avec donc j'ai préféré
dire avec pression que sous pression
voilà à partir de là je me suis fait une
petite métaphore afin d'essayer de
comprendre les stades de la pression que
je vivais dans ma vie et cette métaphore
c'est d'imaginer la pression avec comme
une petite bête une petite bête qui a un
sale caractère et ces petites bêtes sur
mon premier stade en fait c'est comme
donc voilà vous pouvez voir j'ai à peu
près la même tête
il ya une caméra un micro je détestais
ça je c'est vrai du coup en fait je
refuse la petite bête je lui tourner le
dos et elle qu'est ce qu'elle fait bien
tout ce que j'aime pas je rougis tu
stresses qui tremble transpire m'en
faire et du coup c'est le cas que j'ai
vingt quand je passe devant ma classes
de 25 élèves en staps que vous imaginez
eh ben je me mets dans un état horrible
comme aujourd'hui où sur cette photo
sauf que j'aime le parapente
je voulais faire de la compétition et je
voulais performer et je me suis dit que
c'était pas possible en fait de se
mettre dans un état pareil à chaque fois
qu'on a vu une échéance à chaque fois qu
on voulait faire quelque chose de bien
et donc je me suis dit pourquoi pas
aborder la pression sous un autre angle
et déjà pourquoi pas dire oui à cette
petite bête et elle l'est en fait à
l'accepter à lui dire viens dans mon
corps est peut-être qu'on va pouvoir
travailler ensemble et du coup en fait
ça m'a permis de me rendre compte qu'on
peut qu'on peut se trouver commencé à se
connaître et à trouver des techniques
qui vont nous permettre de progresser
typiquement mois avant une compet de
faire de la respiration
alors là j'ai fait la respiration mais
ça marche pas de ouf ça où on peut faire
de l'imagerie montage sais pas si vous
voyez les skieurs avant de prendre la
piste il s'imagine passer dans leurs
portes comme ça ben nous on fait un peu
pareil on s'imagine tourner en rond
comme ça c'est
et puis voilà où simone sinon on
s'imagine tomber et puis parce que ouais
ça arrive alors on tombe pas vraiment
mais on s'imagine les gestes à faire
pour pour justement pas succomber à
cette pression et être au maximum au top
à ce moment là donc voilà est ce que je
fais aussi un truc de ouf que j'ai
découvert il ya pas longtemps ses glands
parle à tout le monde
extériorisant fait là depuis ce matin
annecy lyon lyon paris paris lille à ya
plein de gens qui savent que je viens
ici et que j'ai la trouille mais je les
connais pas je les connais pas et sur
les décollages c'est pareil je vais voir
l'élan et je le redis je stresse c'est
horrible et en fait ça m'a permis de me
rendre compte d'un truc de ouf c'est que
je suis pas la seule en fait on est
plein on est tous humains et on a tous
une part de pression en nous même un
copain qui est champion du monde le lui
aussi l'écran il est costaud d'une
grosse voix quand je vais lui dire j'ai
l'impression d'une double sujet leur
région
et puis euh en fait c'est ouf enfin on
est plein dans le même cas et ça permet
de se rassurer
ça permet de se dire qu'on n'est pas
tout seul et est donc voilà c'est comme
tout ça s'entraîne et on peut progresser
et j'espère qu'en faisant ce type x ben
je progresserai à l'oral devant ma
classe de sept ans le dernier stade de
la pression c'est mon préféré
parce que notamment en fait c'est toutes
les choses auxquelles on s'y attend pas
des choses qui nous font peur les choses
qui nous font stressé des inattendus
comme tombé du ciel
quelquefois pour revenir à la conférence
de tout à l'heure médicale pareil quand
on a des accidents sont nos yeux ne pas
ne pas partir dans un mood où on va se
renfermer en vase dire oh mon dieu ça
m'arrivait je vais tomber je vais mourir
à non faut pas faire ça il faut
justement rester lucide et est en fait
toutes ces choses
[Musique]
en fait tout ça pour vous dire que là
par exemple typiquement cette scène ben
elle m'a fait très peur c'était le
cadeau d'anniversaire de mon meilleur
pote et de mon petit copain alors un
super cadeau
j'ai payé très cher le but c'est de
sauter la tête la première depuis une
montgolfière avec sa voix le pomme verte
en dessous les pieds donc est en fait
une fois loge j'avais la pression de où
je me suis dit mais tu es pétard fait ça
imagine liste uf ans et ton petit ami et
et puis en puisqu'on voit ma tête fin
j'ai vraiment peur puis je suis accroché
dans le vide aussi donc plein de choses
en fait qu'ils sont fait qu'en fait la
pression nous a permis d'être concentrer
un maximum de produits enfin ne pas
faire de faux pas de donner notre
maximum donner notre meilleur tout ce
qu'on savait faire est juste de vivre le
moment pleinement et je remarque que
tous les moments que j'ai kiffé le plus
dans ma vie cc où j'avais le plus de
pression mais vraiment souhaitée d'un
hélico sauter dans l'avion ce jetés
d'une falaise ces trucs incroyables
j'invite tous les jours quoi j'ai peur
n'évite pas dans la même ville mais du
coup voilà je voulais vous faire passer
le message qu en fait la pression au
début c'était quelque chose fin qui me
fait encore voilà très peur et et voilà
ça me fout la frousse mais je pense que
ça nous fait grandir et en fait quand je
dis faites lui confiance je pense que
elle permet de nous connaître et en fait
c'est faites vous confiance et voilà qui
fait amusez vous et puis merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]